salut nous sommes donc aujourd'hui le 28
juillet 2017 si jamais tu vois cette
vidéo dans dix ans beaucoup de personnes
ont rejoint la chaîne ces derniers temps
merci bonjour à vous n'hésitez pas à
regarder dans les anciennes vidéos dans
les playlists parce qu'il ya pas mal de
vidéos qui ont déjà été faites sur la
chaîne bref aujourd'hui ça fait
longtemps je vais vous apprendre un tour
de magie vous allez pouvoir faire durant
tout cet été et durant tout le mois
d'août par exemple on est clairement sur
un tour de magie mentale
c'était arquennes réflexion de processus
derrière une explication logique
j'ai créé ce numéro récemment en partant
sur trois principes vraiment très
basique ce qui fait du coup qu'il est
très facile à faire et je ne révèle pas
un secret le magicien professionnel mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'en
associant ces trois principes de base on
a un tour très bluffant
bluffant au point que j'ai réussi à
avoir un pote magicien professionnel
justement cas pas réussi à comprendre
l'une des étapes qui lui perturbé je me
suis que le plus simple était de vous
faire voir le tour en lui-même j'ai
demandé à ces lignes de la chaîne celi h
devenir juste pour que je fasse le tour
rapidement que vous puissiez voir ce que
ça donne
est ce que tu peux prendre le jeu de
cartes vérifier qu'elles sont
différentes dans l'ensemble et le
mélange est un petit peu une fois que
c'est fait tu te poses devant toi sur la
table c'est bon alors tu vas en prendre
une celle que tu veux dans le jeu tu la
prends tu la regardes tu me la fait pas
voir évidemment
et toi tu la regardes alors toi t'as
mélanger le jeu est à vue qui a été dit
pente mais pas eux
du coup je vais essayer de lui faire
voir pas de n'y a pas de carte de double
de choses comme ça tout va bien c'est
bon tu as retenu de la carte
ok alors ce que tu vas faire c'est que
tu as la poser ici sur le jeu et tu va
refermer la coupe en posant sa part
au-dessus parfait et tu mélanges
derrière
tu es bon tu me repose sur la table et
on va faire un bel éventail avec tout ça
hop avec une seule main ce n'est pas
évident mais ça va je suis et alors tu
va me prendre mon poignet s'il te plaît
on va passer comme ça au dessus des
cartes
là par exemple je ressens quelque chose
d'intéressant je ressens tête de par là
à tanger dit votre soeur mais ça c'est
pas mal c'était quoi ta carte
le 5 de trèfle mais tout à fait céline h
merci beaucoup alors est-ce que vous
avez des pistes élie dédes que ce qui
perturbe ans dans ce tour ce qui est
bluffant c'est que la personne vérifient
les cartes mélange le jeu choisi une
carte elle même c'est pas moi qui tenait
le paquet l'armée elle même dans le jeu
au milieu du jeu et elle mélange elle
même les cartes derrière apparemment il
n'y a pas de manipulation
ben parce que en fait il y en a pas pour
faire ce retour à vos amis et votre
famille à qui vous voulez il vous faut
un jeu de cartes pas forcément le faute
pas forcément jeu de cartes complet pas
forcément un jeu de cartes 9
on sent et c'est ça qui est cool la
première des trois choses à savoir c'est
qu'il faut que vous puissiez identifier
le dos d'une carte facilement donc avec
un petit stylo j'ai fait un gros point
visible ici dans l'angle et dans l'angle
opposé évidemment et là on récupère ce
principe du vieux tours qu'on a tous
appris est enfant on le demande à
quelqu'un de remettre sa carte et nous
pendant ce temps là on regarde celle qui
est là mais c'est archi connus qu'en
rendant unique le dos de la carte on va
garder la même chose sauf qu'on n'a pas
besoin de l'avoir et la personne en face
n'a pas conscience qu'on a une sorte de
repère quelque part
la deuxième chose à savoir c'est que
quand quelqu'un mélange un jeu de cartes
normalement il ya très peu de chances
qui sépare deux cartes qui sont côte à
côte
exemple 2 pickel de coeur sont là quand
elle donne je l'aimais tous les deux
dans le milieu du jeu je mélange un
petit peu les cartes
donc c'est le fameux mélange à la
française je veux pas mélanger non plus
durant trois heures et maintenant si je
regarde dans les cartes
le dos de querelles de pic devait encore
l'un à côté de l'autre
c'est exactement ça il y a une faible
chance que les cartes soient séparés
mais justement elle est très faible et
ça on va utiliser ça le tour étape par
étape
vous avez votre carte où vous avez
gribouillé le dos c'est pas la peine de
faire en sorte que ça soit pas on s'en
fiche
y a que vous qui savez donc vous la
bible
retenez également calé cette carte là en
l'occurrence c'est le joker et vous
mettez cette carte n'importe où dans le
jeu ça n'a aucun intérêt comme au début
de la vidéo sur la présentation de ces
lignes de ces lynch
vous lui demander de vérifier rapidement
le jeu de mélanger toutes les cartes et
d'en prendre une pour elle pendant que
la personne regarde sa carte vous prenez
le jeu pour faire voir l'ensemble des
autres personnes qu'effectivement ils
n'ont pas pu le voir mais les cartes
sont bien différentes et surtout elles
ont bien été mélangés petit malin que
vous êtes c'est à ce moment précis que
vous cherchez où est votre carte abîmée
depuis le départ donc moi le joker il
est juste ici et comme sur la vidéo vous
m'avez vu le faire en direct et j'ai
rien coupé à ce moment là quand j'arrive
à la carte je sépare à cet endroit là
pour mettre le paquet de gauche sur le
paquet de droite et ainsi mettre ma
carte sous le jeu que je repose sur la
table et j'amorce une groupe et à partir
de là vous n'avez plus à toucher au jeu
toujours comme sur la vidéo vous
demander à la personne de remettre sa
carte sur le paquet ici est de rétablir
la coupe donc de mettre ce paquet sur
l'autre et qu'est ce qui va se passer
il va simplement se passe et que la
carte que vous avez émis ici en bas va
se retrouver sur la carte du spectateur
dessus vous demander à la personne de
mélanger un peu le jeu donc le fameux
mélange à la française et de reposer le
paquet sur la table vous n'avez pas
touché le jeu c'est pas vous qui avez
rétabli la coupe c'est pas vous qui
avait mélangé maintenant soit vous
faites un grand ruban vous-même soit
vous demander à la personne d' étaler
les cartes et une fois qu'elle est allée
4 vous cherchez vous du regard ou est ce
qui est votre carte vous avez mis un
petit coup de crayon c'est à dire celle
ci après tout n'est que mise en scène et
cinéma donc vous pouvez lui demander de
tenir le poignet ou faites ce que vous
voulez vous passez votre main dessus
vous vous savez que votre carte avec le
petit point elle est là donc vous
commencez à séparer vous commencez à
séparer et la carte du spectateur sera
toujours sous votre carte avec le coup
de crayon
donc c'est celle ci est comme le mélange
en général ne se sépare jamais de cartes
qui sont collés vous retombez sur la
carte de la personne qui est intéressant
c'est de voir qu'avec des principes très
simple très ancien et très connu en
magie on est très loin de ce que font
les pros on peut quand même faire
quelque chose d'amusant est plutôt
étonnant deux conseils néanmoins pour
bien réussir ce tour
le premier c'est que la personne elle
doit pas non plus mélanger trop
longtemps qu elle mélange plus vous
prenez des risques que ça se séparent le
deuxième set vous entraînez ne le fait
pas une personne si vous l'avez pas fait
au moins
vingt-cinq fois tout seul c'est pas
parce qu'il est très facile à faire que
vous devez pas le répéter un minimum et
le petit pont à savoir qu'est-ce qui se
passe si jamais c'est pas la bonne carte
puisqu'il ya un risque que les deux
cartes se séparent quand même et bien ne
vous excusez pas fait preuve soit de
mauvaise foi rigolote soit fait une
blague dessus et proposez-lui juste de
lui refaire le tour c'est pas très grave
le ciel va pas nous tomber sur la tête
en tout cas moi je continue à faire ce
tour et ma foi
les rares fois où les cartes seront
décoller bien ce serait comme ça et puis
c'est tout et je leur ferai le tour à la
personne je trouve que pour un tour qui
devient bluffant au point d'avoir bluffé
un pote qui est vraiment magicien bas
pour ce risque-là le jeu en vaut la
chandelle si ça vous a plu
n'oubliez pas de cliquer et de vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait et
rendez vous dans deux jours à 11h ciao
[Musique]